okay.
Let's go next to our caller from the seven
81 area code.
Who's calling today from seven, eight one.
Uh, is that me?
That's you.
Who's this?
Uh, this is Alex from the south shore area
in Boston area.
Hey, Alex, what's going on here?
Seven.
That's good.
Uh, I, the question that maybe a little personal,
I know your mom watches the show, so, um,
have you ever tried it?
PSYCHEDELIC drugs?
No, I have not.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Um, I did have a couple other questions actually.
Ready.
Um, so, uh, throw back to your, your interview
with Richard Stallman.
Did you learn anything from that?
Did you like change anything from that?
Um, you know, it's, I, it's so hard to know
what exact interview or clip or story made
me change my view.
I think I learned a lot from Richard Stallman
in general, but I couldn't like give you a
list of what I learned.
Okay.
And, uh, also, um, there was a, there's a
new man, uh, that you might be interested
in interviewing.
Just the recommendation for the show.
Um, Todd weaver I sorta released, he's, he's
about to release a phone for his company that's
like in line with Richard's Feldman's philosophy.
I think it'd be an interesting interview and
uh, if you wanted to interview crazy people
again, uh, the socialist rifle association,
I don't know, just things I wanted to see
on the show.
All right.
Have never heard of either of those, but I
will look into them.
I have it.
I,
okay.
Thanks.
Appreciate it.
Always great to hear it from the south shore.